so you've read the headlines today a
brand spanking new study has found that
doing away with traditional marriage
laws has supposedly reduced suicide
rates among gay teenagers by a whopping
14 percent in states that have embraced
same-sex marriage here are just some of
the glowing headlines PBS Newshour
same-sex marriage laws linked to fewer
youth suicide attempts new study says
Washington Post legalizing same-sex
marriage was associated with fewer youth
suicide attempts new study finds the
Guardian drop in teenage suicide
attempts linked to legalization of
same-sex marriage USA Today study teen
suicide attempts fellows same-sex
marriage was legalized these headlines
which are just a tiny sampling of the
blanket media coverage this study has
received obviously suggest that if
conservatives who just dropped their
gold darned old fashioned opposition to
same-sex marriage kids would stop
killing themselves the study printed in
JAMA Pediatrics concludes that same-sex
marriage policies quote would be
associated with more than 134,000 fewer
adolescents attempting suicide every
year there's only one problem the study
really does not prove that the study
shows a basic correlation between
loosening same-sex marriage law and
suicide rates but it does not show that
same-sex marriage policies reduced
adolescent suicide attempts as the
study's conclusion state in fact the
study itself acknowledges quote our
analysis it does not allow us to
understand the mechanisms through which
implementation of same-sex marriage
policies reduce to adolescent suicide
attempts in other words they say they
know same-sex marriage policies impacted
suicide attempts but they have no idea
how well then they also failed to rule
out some of the most basic confounds for
any sociological study like this
associate get the socioeconomic status
of students themselves is it possible
the students are committing suicide at a
lower rate because their parents are
making more money for example is it
possible that socioeconomic status also
has an outsized impact on particular
groups or how about the social
acceptance of gays and lesbians without
the legislative question the study
admits openly they couldn't check either
of those compounds out they said quote
we also could not control for unmeasured
individual level characteristics
including socioeconomic status or for
unmeasured state characteristics that
may change over time such as religious
affiliation or acceptance of religious
minorities and sexual minorities also
the study fails to explain why non LGBT
students would see their suicide rates
decline in states that approve same-sex
marriage how exactly is that supposed to
work some straight
and kill himself because same-sex
marriage just got approved the research
data shows variability in suicide rates
in states over time as well why would
the suicide rate drop precipitously
between 2005 and 2007 among states that
only legalized same-sex marriage in 2013
or 2014 the study doesn't explain the
study also averages out state data
rather than showing a serious trend
common to all state that means a serious
decline in suicide rate in Hawaii could
wash out an increase in suicide rates in
Delaware look at the charts the pretty
messy and there's a reason for that the
study says quote the analyses on the
association between implementation of
same-sex marriage policies and
adolescent suicide attempts among those
identifying as sexual minorities should
be interpreted with caution giving the
limited data availability on sexual
orientation yet their conclusions are
bold they take what we provide evidence
that implementation of same-sex marriage
policies reduced adolescent suicide
attempts as countries around the world
consider enabling or restricting
same-sex marriage we provide evidence
that implementing same-sex marriage
policies was associated with improved
population health policy makers should
consider the mental health consequences
of same-sex marriage policies so much
for caution here's the bottom line the
study shows correlation not causation it
openly ignores basic data that would be
necessary in order to rule out
confounding factors it also averages
data in order to draw conclusions that
truly are state specific the study
acknowledges its limitations then draws
extraordinarily strong conclusions and
of course the media runs with us this is
how cautious science because it becomes
utterly unconscious conventional wisdom
may be same-sex marriage lowers suicide
rate maybe it doesn't this study doesn't
prove it one way or another but don't
let the media tell you that I'm bettin
Shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
okay lots to get to today we can talk a
little bit about CPAC or as Kellyanne
Conway puts it t pack which is now Trump
Political Action Conference we'll get to
that in just a second plus of the
mailbag today woo why you need to
subscribe so you can be part of the
mailbag and have an extra-juicy long
mailbag today it didn't go like 15
minutes mailbag so it's going to be is
going to be excellent and you're going
to want to be part of it so check that
out and become a subscriber at daily
we're calm but first we have to say
thank you so our advertisers over at
lift so as I have said before my wife
works really long hours because she's a
medical resident she's a doctor and that
means that sometimes she's coming home
really late at night and she's really
tired and the people that she trusts to
bring her home are the folks over at
lift every lift driver is fully vetted
through a 10 point safety standard
including criminal background DMV
background checks you know you're going
to get around quickly and safety all
their cars are supposed to be relatively
new i think they're all within the last
six years which means you're not going
to get some old creep or pulling up in
the nineteen seventy-nine chevy mirada
or whatever today's well okay in any
case the lift app is the way to do this
it's fantastic app and you can tip in
the app which means that the drivers are
happier which means that you're going to
be treated better lift isn't the biggest
ride-sharing app but it is the fastest
growing ride share app for a region
right now lift is offering our listeners
a special deal get three free rides up
to ten bucks each that's a thirty dollar
value when you enter that promo code
Shapiro make sure that when you go to
lift you enter that promo code Shapiro
that's how they know that we sent you
plus you get three free rides up to ten
dollars each which is pretty awesome
just download that free lift app today
enter that promo code Shapiro in the
payment section and you get those three
free rides lift those people that I
trust for my wife to be driven around
when I have to be driven around there
with people I trust and I can't really
speak any more highly of a company than
that okay so let's begin with what's
going on at CPAC aside from somebody
apparently killing themselves and
Richard Spencer being thrown out of the
proceeding so CPAC is always kind of a
zoo I've been to CPAC a bunch of time
solves a lot of fun and this year it
should be particularly fun because it's
Trumpy aright it's Trump your zero so
that means that everybody is very
excited as well they should be there's a
Republican president there's Republican
House there's a Republican Senate there
should be a lot of talk about policy
there should be a lot of talk about
conservatism it is called after all the
Conservative Political Action Conference
except the Kellyanne Conway just showed
up there like a few
minutes ago and apparently she said that
she's making a first public appearance
in weeks she said that I think by
tomorrow this will be T pack she was
asked how has Trump affected the
conservative movement she does I think
by tomorrow this will be T pack meaning
the Trump Political Action Conference
and then she added that conservatism was
quote sclerotic and dusty sclerotic and
dusty so let's start with that no
Conservative Political Action Conference
should probably be advertising from one
of its lead speakers that the founding
ideology and founding idea upon which
his face is sclerotic and dusty as the
hero worship for Trump is is obviously
over-the-top I've been saying this for a
long time call him when he's praised the
money's right celebrated money's right
put on the magic hat when he's right
when he's wrong say that he's wrong but
your philosophy should be what guides
you not your adherence to trumpism and
getting a lot of flak this morning
because I made the same point about
Tucker Carlson so Tucker Carlson over at
Fox News whose show is really very
entertaining because he basically has on
some idiot from the West every so often
and then he hammers them into the ground
and it's really entertaining stuff and
he does the tucker carlson patented the
muse face well he's down split screen
and he's really good at it and he's a
very talented host and obviously getting
huge ratings one of the things that the
Tucker Carlson says in this Atlantic
interview is that he has no set ideology
I mean it's important to note about
Tucker that when he started out early on
as the Atlantic reports on CNN's
crossfire who is basically a mainline
partisan conservative and then after he
left CNN in 2005 he went libertarian and
now he's going full populists and so
Carlton was asked about this here's what
he said he said I'm not much of an
economic conservative I'm not
conservative at all on foreign policy
and then he said so he was asked well
why did you shift all your positions he
says if your politics don't change when
circumstances do you're an idiot you're
a reactionary they says my views are not
super interesting I have a feeling that
you know some of Tucker's use I'm sure
shifted because the political ground map
changed because of Trump isn't because
of this nationalist populism this idea
that you're reactionary if you stick to
your principles but you're not a
reactionary if you shift them in
reaction to event is definitionally
wrong reactionary means you're reacting
to events by shifting your principles in
your philosophies now listen Tucker can
do whatever he wants but it is dangerous
for the movement of the whole to simply
shift its philosophy based around
whatever Trump wants that day or
whatever
Tappin that day that's not a philosophy
that's not that's worth upholding that's
not a set of values that's worth
upholding and so I think that we ought
to be careful before we fall into the
idolatrous trap of turning CPAC into T
pack of recognizing that Trump is only
important in so far as he advances
conservative principles when he breaks
from those conservative principles you
shouldn't be celebrating T back right if
tree pack and seat backs are the same
thing then let's just call it seat back
then CJ its feedback is something
different than CPAC then maybe that is
that ought to be called out a little bit
so that's a preliminary note on on CPAC
it looks like it's gonna be a fantastic
event looks like a lot of fun stuff is
going to be happening there despite a
lot of the confusion that surrounded it
because of everything that happened with
Milo apparently Richard Spencer showed
up and he was immediately tossed out
that is a good idea and it is very funny
a lot of people have been talking this
morning about the idea that if you don't
let certain people speak at your event
this is called no platform and no no
platforming is when there is a state
group that refuses the discriminates on
the basis viewpoint that would be no
platforming it's also no platforming if
you have a group that is dedicated to
free speech like say a university that
says in its mission statement that we're
dedicated to free speech and they're
banning certain people that would be no
platforming it's not no platforming for
a conservative group to not have Bernie
Sanders of the keynote speaker in fact
it's the opposite of no platforming okay
no platforming is but if you think that
no platforming means that you have a
right to sit in my chair and take over
my show for example or you have a right
to take over CPAC main stage or you have
a right to take over a historically
black university and your David Duke
right you don't have a right to do that
doesn't mean that once you're invited
you should be tossed out if somebody
invites you then that is no platforming
to disinvite them but it is really
really really silly to make the
contention that you have a right to
someone else's distribution mechanism
for your message that's actually the
Fairness Doctrine right that's something
the conservatives oppose the left is
been saying for years the talk radio
should be hit with the fairness doctrine
because it's all right wingers and the
right has been saying no these are all
private companies they should be allowed
to say and do what they want you can't
hold both ideas in your mind at once
because they don't mesh okay so no
platforming is a bad thing if you
actually define it the way it's supposed
to be defined if you define no
platforming as everybody should be
allowed to take over any stage that they
want at any time that's just silly
that's just silly and it's actually
indicative of your opinion on by
right so I was violating right too long
as somebody saying something that you
want them to say okay all of that set
the the big issue of the day is actually
not happening at CPAC around the country
CPAC is not it doesn't really make a
blip around the country well it does
make a blip is all these town hall
uprising so there's a lot of talk about
paid protesters supposedly going into
town hall meetings and ripping on
Republican Congress people trying to
intimidate them into leaving Obamacare
in place among the people pushing these
things as Michael Moore here's Michael
Moore talking about the wonders of these
town hall protests you can see just
watching the footage there that the
nobody sings paid if they are there
because they love this country and they
are coming up and you know what you're
just seeing really the first week of
these was crazy to me I mean when you
look at you know we were going back and
looking at footage you're talking about
this today the big town hall thing was
August in 2009 because by that was that
was the August recess and that's when
those town halls happened people getting
yelled at and just be there was a bill
that was about to be passed in the right
position these are the only a month in
right right this is way no no this makes
the Tea Party look like preschool I mean
seriously it makes it that's silly i
mean i love the left claiming the Tea
Party was bad but what's happening now
is good listen everybody has the right
to protest but the fact that the media
continually downgrade and I know that
there was a reporter from political I
think who is downgrading the tea party
claiming that was all fake but this is
all real no no now I will say it's a
mistake for right-wingers to immediately
assume that all of this is fake that
it's all astroturf there's a tendency on
both sides to do this that the tea party
was astroturf by the Koch brothers and
then all these protests are astroturf by
other groups if there's evidence of that
then show me the evidence of that let's
not just throw out the idea that it's
all astroturf have had a lot of evidence
of that I haven't seen tons of evidence
of that I've seen some evidence that
some people are asked for a curved but
the idea that everybody in all of these
rooms is astroturf I don't think that's
right it's difficult to mobilize that
many people on the basis of paying them
five bucks an hour Sean Spicer basically
said this though he came out and he says
a lot of this is just manufactured I
think there's a hybrid there I think
some people are clearly upset but there
is a bit of professional protest or
manufactured base in there but they're
obviously there are people that are
upset but I also think that when you
look at some of these districts and some
of these things it is
is it is not a representation of a
members district or an incident it is a
loud group small group of people
disrupting something in many cases for
media attention no offense it's just I
think that that necessarily just because
they're loud doesn't necessarily mean
that there are many and I think in a lot
of cases that that's what you're seeing
and then there's truth to there's truth
to some of that but just because the
group is very loud doesn't mean they're
a lot of them they all right is very
loud it doesn't mean they're a huge huge
force but it's a political mistake for
spokespeople for presidents to go out
there and say that when you can see a
protest on TV it's all fake tell
astroturf that makes it look like a
denial of reality I said that by the way
way back when okay Robert Gibbs was the
press secretary under Barack Obama and
here's what he said about town hall
protests directed against President
Obama's Obamacare your contention is
what else contention that the anger that
some members of Congress are
experiencing at town hall meetings
especially over health care reform it
can you factor I think some of it is yet
in fact I think you've had groups today
the Conservatives for patients rights
that have bragged about organizing and
manufacturing that anger ok so again it
was bad when Gibbs says that I'm not a
big fan when Spicer says it's just
politically speaking it's not smartness
especially not smart as it plays
directly into the hands of the
protesters so for example here's one
woman who comes out at one of these town
hall events and she says look I'm not a
paid protester I'm here just to talk to
you Thank You senator cotton for being
here today first of all I'm Mary story
from Fayetteville and i am not a paid
protesters
Mary Senate can i address that point
that you it's made yeah I don't really
care anybody here is paid or not you're
all our hands in and I'm glad to hear
from
I know I know I know they've been
there's been some talk about that media
some politician have said that I just
want to say thank you to everyone for
coming out tonight whether you agree
with me or disagree with me this is part
of what our country is all about okay so
you know good response here by Senator
cotton much better response than the
sponge you got from from Sean Spicer but
it does put people in an awkward
position when you say everybody here is
paid and somebody gets up and says I'm
not paid so these town hall events I
want to talk a little bit more about
them and what they're doing but first I
want to say thank you to another one of
our sponsors these are the good folks
over at sea so if you are super into
comedy comedy is your thing and right
now let's face it i think everybody's
into comedy because the world situation
above all is entertaining but if you
need a break and you go home at night
you just want to watch some comedy you
need to go to see so calm and you
subscribe it's like three ninety-nine a
month for see so and it's an endless
amounts of comedy and we're talking
about all of the old episodes of the
office and Parks and Rec and 30 rock and
it's got all the old episodes of Monty
Python the entire backlog the Saturday
Night Live back when it was good he's
got all sorts of new shows that they are
producing a bunch of which are really
really funny if you go to see so calm
right now SE ESO calm right now and sign
up for a month free with the promo code
been a check out number one they know we
sent you number two yes you get to try
it out for months and see how great it
is and it really is great I mean
basically at night my wife comes home
from having you know worked on people
who are dying there she's a doctor and
and we sit down in front of c cell and
we just and we just lose loser I mean
it's really funny it's really funny
stuff C so calm promo code Ben and you
can stream all the comedy but you want
anytime anywhere for 399 a month it is
the best comedy that is available you
get all the late night comedy the day
after it airs also if you just wanna be
up on the news and see what all the late
night hosts are saying you can do that
plus you get all the stands up from
people like Louie CK who no matter how
lefty is Louie CK is really really funny
and you can get all of his stand-up so
it is the one stop shop for comedy and
that's why you need to go to see so calm
subscribe for 399 a month for right now
use that promo code been try it out for
a month and see if you like it I promise
you you will it's really really funny
stuff really entertaining stuff okay so
back to these town hall event so these
town hall events have basically become a
way for the left to
put sympathetic faces on TV to talk
about how terrible would be if they
repeal Obamacare so here's an example of
this a woman gets up and she's asking
Tom cotton about her husband and I just
want to play this because I think that
it's indicative of what exactly the
media are trying to do and the sort of
narratives that come into play here
we're going Medicare of my way not your
way my way I got a husband dying and we
can't afford let me tell you something
if you can get us better cover sins in
go for it let me see what we have put a
lot of benefits that we need we have
twenty nine dollars per month from us
can you be back can you with all the
concessions heart fair but open-heart
surgery something is gift worth trying
twenty-nine dollars per month and he's a
hard worker now so I can I dollars for
me okay so the reason that I play this
is because I think this is what the
media are looking for what they're
looking for is exactly this they're
looking for women to get up there and
say my husband's dying keep Obamacare
and obviously your heart goes out to the
woman whose husband has a serious health
problem obviously obviously but to
pretend that she has extra moral
authority because she's experiencing
tragedy it's just not true and something
left likes to play but only selectively
so after nine eleven they said that the
people who the widows in 911 the jersey
girls they call them they said that they
had impeccable moral authority because
they had spouses who died on 911
therefore they should be making policy
for the whole country and you heard this
from Maureen tab but there's a when I
think his code pink when cindy sheehan
who had a son who died in Iraq when she
started talking marines out immediately
called said that she had absolute Laurel
authorities not just moral authority
godlike moral authority to determine
what policy should be and what policy
would be but when it come to pass
Smith's I mean Michelle Malkin makes
this point she's right when it comes to
pass Smith the mother of sean smith who
was killed in benghazi she comes down
because my son was killed in benghazi
and that's a problem and the entire
media ignores her where'd the moral
authority go it's just gone
out right no more moral authorities been
debunked and the reason for that is
because the less likes to use tragedy as
a club with which to beat it to enemies
but it will not allow there to be a
common rule about tragedy you know why
because tragedy can't be a common rule
because the vast majority of people in
life have experienced some form of
tragedy or another and it doesn't make
them experts on the topic it doesn't
mean that they should actually do create
the create the policy in fact there's a
good case to be made that if you've
experienced tragedy on a particular
score you should be the person who's
least likely to make the policy the
logic being that if you're a doctor and
your son comes into the waiting room
with with a cancerous tumor you
shouldn't be the one to operate on
you're too close to the situation your
empathy is skewing how you're actually
going to treat the situation it's why we
all take doctor's advice rather than
researching it on our own and then just
determining that we're going to do X Y
or Z like we do our own research knowing
that we combine that empathy with actual
expertise and expert advice there's
going to be professor Paul bloom at Yale
University he's our an entire book on
the fact that empathy makes for bad
policy he says emotional empathy is a
different matter when it comes to
guiding our moral judgments in political
decisions recent research and
neuroscience and psychology shows that
empathy makes us biased tribal and often
cruel why easy to have empathy for this
lady right here maybe you're being cruel
to the millions of people who are forced
to buy health insurance that they can't
afford or forced off of health insurance
that they could afford and is what
Bernie Sanders said the other day says
you know what what good is it to have
the right to buy health care if you
can't afford it and the answer is number
one it is the market system that makes
health care affordable but number two
it's a lot worse to me to have a system
where you can afford health care you're
not allowed to get it because of Bernie
Sanders that seems worse to me what
professor bloom faces empathy is
activated when you think about a
specific individual the so-called
identifiable victim effect but it fails
to take broader considerations into
account which is why people will give
tons of money when they see a wounded
baby seal during a hurricane but they
won't give any money to one hundreds of
thousands of people being slaughtered in
Syria because one is an identifiable
victim and the other is not an
identifiable victim the point being here
that when you foreign policy for
millions of people's for millions of
people then it is imperative that you
put your empathy to the side so you can
make good policy doesn't mean you
shouldn't be empathetic doesn't mean you
shouldn't feel for this lady
this idea that the left keeps trotting
out victims and then we're supposed to
make policy based on the fact that
certain policies have certain effects
but the statistical impact is is either
small or or is balanced out by other
factors that's really a bad way to make
policy but this is what the left is
trotting out in clip 16 we get this from
another woman she does the same sort of
thing my family has been in the Ozarks
since the 1800s we are historically
Republican family we're farming family
we're in an are a family we're an army
family aside from inheriting their
patriotism and their work ethic I
unfortunately inherited a incurable
genetic connective tissue disorder I
qualify for Medicare but unfortunately
it's equal for me since only two of my
doctors who are the only doctors and
over 500 mile radius who are familiar
with my condition accept Medicare
without the coverage for pre-existing
conditions I will die will you commit to
replacement in the same way that you
have committed to the repeal
I mean who's doin to get the standing
ovation for the question not even for
the answer righteous for the question
and again the idea is that her suffering
confers a certain level of value to her
opinion again you have to feel awful for
this person you have to feel terrible
for this person and I promise you that
if she started a charity fund people
would raise tons of money for her
because again that identifiable victim
effect means that our empathy for her
means that we would help her out but
shifting it was crafting broad public
policy around one person and their
suffering in their tragedy is just not
it's just not good public policy it just
isn't it just isn't so it's also
worthwhile noting by the way that all
these Republicans have already said that
they want pre-existing conditions to be
covered which is something with which I
disagree because that doesn't actually
that doesn't actually look like
insurance anymore but you know that's
because I'm talking about broad public
policy not about having to win
reelection when you've got these sort of
sympathetic stories being trotted out on
routine basis okay before we go to break
here I've said before that we all should
everybody needs to subscribe to daily
wire calm eight dollars a month you can
subscribing be part of the mailbag today
and and that's going to be a really
solid mailbag so we're going to get into
that in just a little bio to subscribe
right now you can be part of this week's
mailbag we do take live questions on the
mailbag so we'll do all of that but
right now if you subscribe annually you
also get a copy of the DVD of the arroyo
and I've been talking about this
fictional film that takes place on the
border i want to show you some of the
trailer so you know what you're getting
when you subscribe you ever been to
Mexico looks just like this same land
same sky everybody wants to be here you
have a wonder about that
over 1500 in the last six weeks that's
just on my land that's just the ones
I've counted we got no problems at all
here the politician telling I get it
times are hard in our community we all
want a magical cure to our problems
about another dead kid on the land third
one this year quilters do pretty much as
they please yeah about that mess up in
Phoenix whole family slaughtered by the
cartel what am I supposed to do is not
my job to enforce federal law then whose
job is it hell ain't nobody going to
help us down in here not on the fam Nova
we nothing but a nuisance to them except
when it comes time to write the check
maybe it's time we helped ourselves if
you hurt my family you should have told
that boy to shoot me on sight hello
trying to avoid the ok corral or you
didn't those eggs is really going to be
live streaming it on Facebook the entire
movie seeing it as a taste of it on
friday so check that out and right now
to get that annual subscription you get
a free copy of the Arroyo okay so that
ends our our Facebook and and youtube
today but go over to daily wire calm and
subscribe or listen later at iTunes we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
you